for all of the can't-miss TV going on
there are lots of series critics say you
can go ahead and skip the following
shows are our picks for the very worst
of 2018 ABC promoted this midseason
replacement as the triumphant return of
Zach Braff who was away from TV for
almost a decade after scrubs finished
its long run what those ads didn't
include was a discussion about what Alex
Inc actually is he would appear to be a
typical family comedy about a goofy dad
his long-suffering wife and their kids
but it's also about a guy who has a
midlife crisis starts his own company
and documents the journey with a podcast
based on the true story of start-up host
Alex Blumberg Alex Inc brings the thrill
of watching people talking into
microphones to the visual medium of
television
it's about as exciting as it sounds
especially since everyone on the show
treats Alex like he's an absolute genius
for deciding to do a podcast nobody when
you do it's amazing
who doesn't love people who do podcast
talking about how smart they are because
they do podcasts remember that Disney
movie max Keeble 'he's big move about a
middle schooler who pranks all his
bullies when he learns his family is
moving but then has to deal with all the
consequences when they don't actually
move the CW's breezy dramedy life
sentence has that same premise but
replaces schoolyard pranks with the much
more tragic subject of cancer a young
woman named Stella thought she was dying
and for years lived every day like it
was her last only to be cured and left
with the consequences of her impulsive
decisions if you enjoy getting some
laughs out of a character being
humiliated for thinking she was going to
die life sentence is the show for you
there's rarely a shortage of medical
dramas on TV so if a new one is going to
stand out it has to give viewers a hook
early for the resident that involved
establishing its lead character dr.
Conrad Hawkins as a medical rogue who
plays by his own rules by having him
pour out an energy drink on someone's
car and then peel off his shirt to show
a hilariously massive death before
dishonor tattoo sadly that's about as
much character development as you get
before the show starts asking you to
side with Hawkins as he makes rash
decisions and ignores his superiors
because he has a gut
about what crazy medical procedure to go
for he doesn't come across as heroic
just arrogant and smarmy a
standard-issue hard to like antihero
story like house without the charm or
madmen without the style I have only one
rule covers everything I'm never wrong
sar mad zoo Cree has plenty of talent
and intensity but since Grey's Anatomy
felt pressure at the start of its 14th
season than this show does in its first
it looks like the resident is terminal
splitting up together is familiar in
that it's family sitcom about
overwhelmed parents raising their kids
it does however offer up a twist we
haven't seen before mom and dad are in
the process of getting a divorce but
rather than have one parent move out
both parents stay in the house and keep
separate living quarters to provide
their kids with a stable home situation
while that's a very modern and
true-to-life situation it's a hard sell
for a silly little sitcom considering
that TV audiences mostly know star Jenna
Fischer from watching her sloper and
romances Pam on the office seeing her
quip through the collapse of a marriage
is just a little too depressing for
laughs here's something that sounds like
a fever dream co-created by
oscar-nominated actor Empire star and
Hollywood oddball Terrence Howard and
his wife Fright Club is a hybrid of a
reality prank show and a dark comedy
with a horror movie premise Howard
invites his friends and a fan who thinks
she won a contest to a spooky haunted
estate in the spooky haunted estate
capital of America New Orleans then
Howard and his cohorts scare their
victims with elaborate schemes in the
form of swamp monsters and gory
realistically rendered boudu rituals
before gently letting his victims know
they've been pranked the audience
however had no such reveal believe it or
not this show was actually real Ricky
Gervais is a TV legend for co-creating
and starring in the original British
version of The Office but his latest
project isn't a single-camera comedy or
nuance character study instead child
support is basically a more convoluted
humiliating version of are you smarter
than a 5th grader see if you can follow
this bizarre setup in a TV studio host
Fred Savage asks an adult contestant a
trivia question if they answer correctly
their response is compared to the answer
given by a member of a pan
of adorable children who were asked the
same questions by Gervase in what looks
like a focus group situation in a creepy
conference room if the kid answers
correctly the adult player stays in the
game if the adult was wrong they can
save themselves if a kid panelist
answers correctly if the kid is wrong
too then the adult is eliminated exactly
the kind of simple easy-to-follow setup
that a great gameshow needs or not this
is worse than the Dalton bugs maybe
Gervase thought a game show about
children should feel like it was
designed by one all in the family was
among the most popular and controversial
shows of the 1970s through Carol
O'Connor's portrayal of Archie Bunker a
stubborn conservative at best and
unrepentant racist at worst who was
constantly arguing with his son-in-law
writers could debate the social issues
of the day in 2018 the CBS sitcom the
neighborhood obviously emulates that
classic formula it's about a
middle-class white couple who move into
a predominantly african-american area
where they're happily oblivious to the
challenges their neighbors face until
they're called out on it by their new
neighbor it's one thing to never quite
get to the provocative progressive
territory of all in the family but with
formulaic and frankly boring stories it
doesn't even come close to
contemporaries like blackish either
we're not from around here there's
certainly nothing wrong with the TV
series that aims to tell relatable
truths about contemporary life but
sometimes a show is a little too devoted
to encapsulating a realistic experience
and becomes an annoying unpalatable slog
I feel bad is that kind of show feeling
like a retread of countless other
stressed mom sitcoms like Roseanne or
the middle I feel bad is about a video
game artist who constantly wanders often
aloud if her work life suffers because
of her family commitments and if her
family life suffers because of her
demanding job oh and if those weren't
enough cliches for you don't worry
I feel bad also adds in a dopey husband
and meddling parents it's just a shame
they forgot to include things like good
jokes and well-developed stories
obnoxious and self-centered people who
have no idea how loathsome they are can
be prime targets for comedy but what
happens when the writers don't seem to
have any clue that their characters are
unwashed
you'll be awful it turns out what
happens is HBO's camping from Lena
Dunham and Ginny Connor the eight
episodes show agonizingly takes place
over just a single weekend it follows a
birthday for a whiny suburban
milquetoast named Walt played by doctor
who's David Tennant that's planned down
to the minute by his wife Katherine
played by Jennifer Garner they're joined
by a series of annoying friends and
associates played by hard trying
well-liked actors as they swim hang out
and passive-aggressively gripe at one
another it's all the fun of hanging out
with people you hate for an entire
weekend but with the added twist that
everyone involved is getting paid for it
except you the world's most famous
Baldwin brother has done pretty much
everything you can do on television from
sitcoms like 30 rock soap operas like
Knott's landing game shows on the
revival of match game and even frequent
appearances on Saturday Night Live the
only thing he had left was a talk show
but thanks to ABC he can finally check
that one off his bucket list
unfortunately that's not actually a good
thing
the Alec Baldwin show is just not good
talk-show interviewing is a unique skill
a host must ask simple but interesting
questions that set up their guests to
speak at length in an entertaining
fashion
unlike the established hosts who
actually excel at it like Stephen
Colbert and Jimmy Kimmel Baldwin
frequently interrupts his very patient
guests so that he can tell a story about
his favorite subject Alec Baldwin it
seems like audiences weren't as into
Baldwin as he was himself though it did
so badly that ABC moved it from its
prominent Sunday night timeslot to bury
it in the hinterlands of Saturday